بعد تحذير رئيس روسي فلاديمير بوتين
بريطانيا من تزويد اوكرانيا بذخيره التي
تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم اكدت وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا تحاول عمدا
تقديم معلومات مضلله وقال متحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع ردا على تصريحات بوتين
استخدم اليورانيوم المنظف في قضاء ايفا
خارقه لدروع لعقود كما اكد انه مكون بل
مكون مكون اذا لا علاقه له باسلحه او
القدره النوويه مشيرا الى ان موسكو تدرك
ذلك تماما واضافت الدفاع البريطاني ان
البحوث المستقله خلصت الى ان تاثير
استخدام
منخفض في المقابل اعتبرت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجي الروسيه ماريا لنقل قذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم
وشدد الزخاروف على ان لندن تصاعد الصراع
في اوكرانيا الى مرحله جديده وتؤكد نيه
الغرب الجماعي تدمير اوكرانيا مؤكده ان
استخدام قضائف اليورانيوم يعد مظهرا من
مظاهر الاباده الجماعيه ضد السكان بدوره
حذر وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو من صدام
نووي محتمل قائلا ان خطوات اقل متبقيه قبل
حدوث هذا الصدام بين روسيا والغرب وفق ما
نقلت الروسيه جاء تحضير شويغو بعدما سئل
من الصحافيين عما اذا كانت نيه بريطانيا
من تزويد اوكرانيا بقذائف اليورانيوم
المنظم تعني ان العالم قد بات على بعد
خطوه واحده من حدوث صدام نووي